hi i'm danny ceo and here's a brand new
episode of do
just one thing
and today we're solving the problem of a
smelly
blender and it happens all the time i go
away for a weekend and i come home and
somebody decided to make gazpacho or
some kind of a spicy oily
messy dish in the blender that's really
going to impact the taste of say
my shake in the morning well you don't
have to get rid of the blender you can
clean it you can deodorize it and yes
you can disinfect it
in just one easy step so the very first
step
is you want to clean it as good as you
can and put in
a big cup of hot water into your blender
and the trick that we want to use here
is that instead of scrubbing the blender
or taking it apart we're going to use
what the blender does best which is
blend to actually clean itself the next
thing is sort of a chemistry class thing
and we're going to use white vinegar we
love white vinegar
it's a mild acid it's completely natural
about one cup
of white vinegar goes into the blender
and it's going to really help sort of
clean and disinfect the inside of the
blender
now to give it a little bit of some
friction and you know what happens when
you mix
baking soda with white vinegar well you
get a really
beautiful chemical reaction so we're
going to put in like three
tablespoons let's see look at it fizzing
away scrubbing the insides
getting all those odors and stains off
of the canister and
really clean on the inside and then one
more thing
that we want to do is i save my lemons
and what we love about lemons is that
lemons are a natural
whitening agent and so instead of
getting a brand new lemon i use these
for a salad the other day i just saved
these toss these
right into the blender and now we were
away
to clean disinfect and deodorize our
dirty blender just turn it on and slowly
let it work away
the one thing is you don't want to eat
this so
what you do want to do is dump it in the
sink
give it a good rinse and guys look at
this hot water
white vinegar a little baking soda and
some used lemons
your blender is as good as new
who wants margaritas if you're gonna
post this onto your social media we
would love it if you tagged the drew
barrymore show in your post
and be sure to check out more tips
tricks inspiration recipes and more
at the drew barrymore show.com and
always
don't forget i got my brand new magazine
naturally danny zio
now on newsstands actually the soup was
made in a blender
[Music]
you